Hello Internet
In my last video about Pluto you may have noticed,
that i said aloud the names of every planet except one:
This one
And that was no accident,
but rather the result of carefull script editing.
Because, where i grew up,
i learned that the name of the seventh planet
is pronounced "yoo-Rain-us".
Of course to a kid "yoo-Rain-us" sounds an awful lot like "your-Anus",
which is how i and everyone i knew ended up saying the name.
Which is
funny when you're a child, but becomes a bit of a problem, if you grew
up
and trying to teach scientific facts about the planet.
for example:
Uranus has a ring around it.
Astronomers have discoverd a dark spot on Uranus.
Uranus is a gas giant.
Uranus is surrounded by methane.
There is a solution to this problem, the alternative pronunsiation of
the name,
wich goes:
YUR-in-us
And most scientists in public roles do use this pronunciation.
But for me YUR-in-us is still problematic.
Sure, it's better then your-Anus, but it's still URINE-us.
And perhaps i'm just childish, but when someone else says YUR-in-us,
i still hear your-ANUS in my head and it just draws more
attention to the unfortunate name.
The tragedy is, it didn't have to be this way.
The seventh planet from the sun is unique because it's the first Planet we discovered.
For all of human history the sixth closest planets were big enough or bright enough to see with just our
limited simian eyes.
But the next planet was to dim to see until our telescope technology got good enough for british
astronomer Wilhelm Herschel to spot it in 1781.
Understandably though he didn't think he discoverd a new planet, since from the
rise of modern humans 50 thousand years earlier until that Thursday no one ever had.
But discover he did and so choose a
name he must
and Herschel, being the good subject of the crown that he was,
christened his new planet "The Georgium Sidis",
which means "The Georgian Star".
And the George in "The Georgian Star" was King George the third the reigning monarch.
While King George liked the name, the rest of the world did not
and decided that perhaps Herschel wasn't the best guy to name the
new planet after all
and quickly decided to come up with alternatives of their own.
One suggestion was Neptun, which is confusing to us now, but at the time the planet that would become Neptun had
not yet been found.
A more obvious alternative was to name the planet Herschel after the man who discovered it.
Even in Great Britain the name "The Georgium Sidis" proofed a bit stuffy for some, so variance like "The Georgian Planet",
or just "Georgium" were also used.
Though never, as you might have heard, "George".
Sidenote here:
While researching this video i found a lot of websites claiming that the seventh planet was almost
named "George", but i was never able to find a primary source for this.
As best i could tell searching from documents
from the time no one ever suggested this name.
I checked with the Royal Institution who, since 1799, has been
promoting sciences awesomeness from the heart of London and whose videos you should now go watch,
and they confirmed the
name "George" was never on the table, because to so casual refer to the King at the time would have been disrespectful.
And disrespect a monarch is never a good idea.
Especially one who is slowly loosing his mind from a genetic disorder, but that's a story for another time.
Anyway, another real suggestion for the new planets name came from Johann Bode who suggested the greek god of the sky.
When a colleague of Bode discovered the 92 element in 1789, he named it Uranium to support Bode's choice and try and
end the debate.
Perhaps because these two were German it might not have occurred to them how the word would eventually be corrupted in english.
Though it's also hard to know how english speakers in the 1780's and 90's
would have pronounced the name.
But since the word anus was in the language then,
it seems unlikely, that this particular pronunciation would have been popular.
It may also have been pronunced with a flat "a" to sound like
yoo-RA-nus,
or something more like the Greek name oo-RON-ohs.
These names competed with each other over decades,
for example:
still in 1823, the Encyclopedia Britannica list the planet as "Herschel",
notes the alternative names
and then proceeds to carefully word the rest of the artikel to avoid naming the planet again.
With you a dear modern day
viewer know that eventually this alternatives faded and left this name triumphant.
Which leaves someone like me with
my terrible pronunciation longing for history to have taken a different path.
The name "Herschel" might have made the planet sound a bit like a boring accountant rather than a very intresting planet
it actually is,
but this would still be a much better name than what we have.
Neptune is obviously a fine planetary name
though picking this might have just delayed the problem.
finally "The Georgium Sidis" is a bit awkward and in sillier moments i wish that Herschel had just been more direct and
named it "King George",
because how fun would that make it to teach kids the list of planets today.
Mercury, Venus, Earth, Mars, Jupiter, Saturn, King George and Neptun.
In classrooms such an unusual name would change the planet from a thing to avoid to a starting point for a
discussion about what makes that Planet different
and how astronomy and our view of the universe change and
progress over time.
But my impractical dreams aside we're stuck with this name,
which for me means choosing between
the pronunciation which comes naturally and is terrible, or the unnatural awkward one which is still unsatisfactory.
So what's a man to do?
In the end, probably follow the lead of the Encyclopaedia Britannica and avoid the name when
possible.
Which is a sad fate for the planet in our solar system with such an interesting story to tell.
Seriously people, could we at least agree to switch the pronunciation back to the greek oo-RON-ohs? It's clearly so
much better.